hoy el pueblo klein en el estado de
santa catarina espera ansiosamente el
fallo de la corte suprema de brasilia
que podría cambiar su destino
es muy triste la sociedad brasileña
necesita entender que no queremos nada
que pertenezca a otra persona sólo
queremos lo que está documentado que son
las tierras tradicionales del pueblo
schoklender terroristas de el estado de
santa catarina desalojo a los godos
klein de sus tierras tras una
interpretación literal del polémico
marco temporal un mecanismo legal que
nació en 2009 tras un conflicto entre
indígenas y agricultores por el cual se
estableció que las tierras ocupadas por
los indígenas les pertenecen si se
encontraban en ellas cuando se ratificó
la constitución en
antes nos mataban con armas de fuego
lentamente y 11 ahora nos matan con
lapiceros poco a poco planeta de elevada
dimensión el jaguar y mientras tanto en
brasilia se desarrolla la mayor
manifestación indígena de la historia
del país desde hace más de una semana
miles de personas presionan a los 11
jueces del tribunal supremo- los
indígenas quieren proteger sus tierras
que se encuentran en su mayoría en 9
estados brasileños y son esenciales para
la preservación del ecosistema de la
amazonía contra la minería y la
agroindustria
de marcar tierras indígenas es de marcar
y garantizar la vida de la humanidad
somos el 5 por ciento de la población
mundial pero protegemos alrededor del 83
por ciento de la biodiversidad mundial
de marcar el territorio es garantizar la
respiración del planeta
en repetidas ocasiones el presidente ya
ir bolsonaro ha declarado que los
pueblos originarios constituyen menos
del 1 por ciento de los brasileños
mientras que viven en más del 13% del
territorio que debería ser explotado